how do you get to that point where you
both understand each other both you both
like what's the conversation you have
say like we we don't talk about
masculine and feminine at all we don't
talk about sexual energy you don't talk
about sex what do we do okay so give me
a little bit more of an example like a
moment like a moment where you'd want to
bring this into conversation or you know
somebody well I just mean like what if
you know what if there's a yearning to
improve improve intimacy right and like
at what what do you say when do you say
it and how do you say it were you like
let's figure it let's let's learn how to
do this better
right so it's very tricky if your
partner is masculine for you to bring
that I get this question all the time do
it shows up where women will tag their
partners on my Instagram posts like me
or or buy this book or that kind of
thing right basically what they're
saying is they're taking the directional
space they're taking they're using their
masculine they're using direction to
address this issue of wanting more love
and connection because you as a feminine
essence being which you are will never
have enough love and connection there
can always be more there could always be
richer it could always be deeper can
always and it's beautiful that's the
beauty of the feminine is that more love
is always possible and it's always
there's a part of our hearts that my
heart - that always wants that the
masculine is have the same feeling about
freedom freedom from demand you know
what I'm saying right freedom from
demand freedom is freedom from you know
freedom from demand really that's that's
the big thing right so you've got these
two kind of polarities that are already
at odds a little bit right and I think
we just need to acknowledge that because
it's it's it's
that you know God set it up that way but
the masculine is just always craving
more freedom and the feminine is always
creating more connection and so if you
are a feminine being and you're having
this impulse for more love then the way
to do it is to just amplify so it's not
that it's your responsibility at all but
you're gonna be more predisposed to
wanting it than him if he's masculine
he's going to be less interested in the
relating not you he I'm sure he loves
you to death would die for you right
he's but he's gonna be less interested
in the relating than you because your
essence is your Nate your a love driven
being and so you've got the masculine
predilection for freedom which often
shows up as watching TV we're owning out
in some way zoning out in some way got
games
it's like zoning after in some so you
have to be more your the pleasure and
radiance and sweetness and devotion that
comes through your body has to be more
magnetic than the pole to the football
game hmm hmm which in your case might be
kind of hard
you
[Music]